je voulais juste rapidement réagir par
rapport à ma dernière vidéo est ce que
c'est vrai que bon les réactions étaient
un petit peu
voilà je voulais simplement fait
m'excuser parce que c'est pas que j'ai
pas reçu énormément d'insultés je pense
que j'ai postée sur le net quoi vraiment
comme il faut j'ai tout fait comme il
fallait et j'ai fait des blagues un peu
trash oui bien sûr bon j'ai eu j'ai reçu
bien sûr un ou deux grosses [ __ ] mais
bon grosse [ __ ] c'est pas vraiment une
insulte
si je veux dire pas de vivre la peine de
mort où on va passer ta mère au mixeur
ou je n'ai pas de réel engouement
voilà donc forcément je me remets un peu
en question que je me demande demande un
peu à côté de quoi je suis passé il ya
même des gens ils sont comme ça c'est
bon c'est rigolo c'est du second degré
c'est de l'humour on a compris ça
dénonce non en fait
mais mes respecter l'esprit du web
l'esprit du net je voulais juste vous
dire c'est pas parce que le monde va mal
qu'il faut arrêter de s'insulter
justement il faut continuer il faut y
aller encore plus encore plus fort pour
leur montrer qui ils n'auront pas cet
esprit qu'on a sur le web
notre notre temple de la culture et de
la connerie profonde et notre road à la
faute d'orthographe continue on continue
on insulte on nous les uns les autres et
ce peu importe les classes sociales
insultant les noirs insultant les blancs
insultant les lieux les bébés les
pauvres les handicapés jeu quand c'était
vraiment important de faire passer ce
message je pense était important de
candidats s'est égaré dans mon garage
merci